and finally new rule the next time you
hear someone say you may be cursed to
live in interesting times punch them in
the face because after two years of
Trump chaos that line isn't cute anymore
in fact you have my blessing as your
political rabbi to take the rest of the
year off from following politics but but
not till next week because we have one
more show
but 2018 has been a year I think in
which we all asked ourselves how could
something seem so endless and yet also
go by so fast it's like if Quentin
Tarantino made Gone with the Wind and
you're watching it on an airplane and
the airplane is crashing into a mountain
of cocaine Trump is the Santa Claus of
chaos and every night is Christmas Eve
he somehow everywhere in the world only
he's not bringing you anything he's
breaking the [ __ ] you already had that's
him on the roof but now he's coming down
the chimney and eating your cookies now
he's kissing mommy and grabbing her
[ __ ]
he's the gift that never stops taking
each morning you confront the news with
the same thought stormy Daniels said she
had when Trump sat down next to her on
the bed here we go
by the way Michael Cohen paid stormy to
go away but stormy did not go away she
stuck to trump all year like toilet
paper on a shoe anyway every day it
seems like it's the same thing you open
your newsfeed face pas in fact I think
as long as Trump is president the
facepalm should replace the handshake
that's a way for two people greeting
each other to acknowledge yes everything
is a [ __ ] show and no there's nothing
new to say about it hey Bob how you
doing
hi Sara
now all year long and going back to
before the election I have been calling
the Trump phenomenon a slow-moving coup
well this week it started moving a
little faster Matthew Whitaker this is
what I'm talking about
in third-world dictatorships the chief
law enforcement officers main
qualification is he doesn't enforce the
law officials of independent mind are
hounded out or shoved aside this isn't a
cabinet anymore it's the Queen's corgis
Whitaker wants to shut down the Russian
investigation despite the fact that in
march against the advice of everyone
Trump called Putin to congratulate him
on winning his election and also our
election he then he then met Putin in
July and that meeting secret his deal
with Kim jong-un secret his taxes secret
what is happening to America we know
less about our government than what goes
into jerky in mid 2017 I first read you
my dictator checklist but since this
week is the week we now have added
install your personal protector as head
of the Justice Department after adding
in September install your personal
protector on the highest court let's
review the dictator list one more time
you're a narcissist who likes to see his
name and face on buildings you will
point family members to positions of
power you hold rallies even when you're
not running and they are scary you talk
about jailing the press and political
opponents you want to hold military
parades and muse openly about being
president for life you use your office
for personal financial gain you love
other dictators you lie so freely your
supporters don't know what the truth is
anymore and don't care
for a coup to work it is first necessary
for truth itself to be destroyed as well
as the people who try to report it so
the dictator is free to say anything and
his followers believe it
adding to that dictator checklist we now
have state TV in this country an actual
propaganda channel where the reporters
openly endorsed the leader and we have
people who oversee the elections they
are running in in August of this year
Trump's semi-liquid Mob mouthpiece GUI
Giuliani said truth is in truth this has
been deep thoughts with Nosferatu
[Applause]
so truth isn't truth the press is the
enemy of the people there are
alternative facts there's no proof of
anything what you see in here isn't
what's happening and you know at some
point people go you know what fine [ __ ]
it truth is and truth facts aren't facts
what I see isn't happening nothing is
real and nothing to get hung about
strawberry fields forever please pass
the joints or some crack because I can
still reason and it hurts